bene buonasera a tutti
a differenza di stefano io vengo dal
passato io vengo precisamente dal 5
settembre del 1953 e il 50 anni io ho
visto tante cose ho visto affermarsi la
radio
ho visto affermarsi e declinare il
tormentone domenicale della radiolina a
transistor che era quella cosa che i
mariti si portavano con sé moglie
naturalmente acquistava e lui ascoltava
tutto il calcio minuto per minuto
ho visto l'affermarsi la televisione
all'interno delle case di tutti noi
prima raiuno successivamente rai due con
un'antennina che veniva appiccicata a
quella esistente
poi ho cominciato ad arrivare che tutti
gli altri canali ed è diventato uno
strumento di massa e poi ho visto
affermarsi all'interno di tutte le
nostre case gli elettrodomestici cose
che assolutamente non esistevano e poi a
fianco di quella grande cosa che fu
l'edilizia popolare che di e del modo a
milioni di persone nel nostro paese di
vivere in ambienti dignitosi
ho visto il nascere e poi il rapido
declino della grande industria di massa
quell'industria che nella nostra vulgata
comune chiamiamo industria fordista quel
modo di organizzare la produzione ha
condizionato anche tutti i nostri
ambienti urbani non solo dal punto di
vista della sostenibilità ambientale ma
anche dal punto di vista dei nostri
stili di vita dei nostri orari ea fianco
del modo con cui quella grande fabbrica
ha condizionato l'ambiente urbano ha
condizionato anche tutta la pubblica
amministrazione
i nostri ambienti urbani in gran parte
sono rimasti legati a quel modello
ho visto i primi computer quei primi
computer avevano una particolarità al di
là della potenza di calcolo non erano
collegati ad internet le loro funzioni
nascevano e morivano in un'unica
attività che tutti noi facevamo potrei
continuare a lungo sulle tante cose che
ho visto nel corso dei primi 50 anni
poi dieci anni fa è cominciato una
rivoluzione silenziosa della quale noi
siamo in gran parte inconsapevoli ed è
quella con la quale l'ambiente urbano e
tutti noi facciamo i conti
quotidianamente me lo sono dimenticato
in giacca dieci anni fa steve job ha
presentato l'iphone ovvero un oggetto
che consentiva indipendentemente dal
luogo in cui tu eri di poterti
connettere alla rete per la prima volta
non importa dove tu eri poteri ricevere
o spedire una mail potevi o ricevere e
attraverso un browser collegarsi a una
rete vedere ciò che c'era potevi
ascoltare musica e via via ricordatevi
nel corso di questi dieci anni a quell
affare si sono aggiunte infinita
quantità di funzioni una mappa che ci
consente di girare tranquillamente una
città fino ai giorni nostri diventare
una sorta di strumento di interazione
fra lui e gli oggetti potete chiamarlo
iphone potete chiamarlo samsung potete
chiamarlo huawei non ha importanza ci
possiamo connettere possiamo lavorare in
mobilità
la seconda rivoluzione collegata a
questa che ugualmente ci ha cambiato
tutto è quella cosa che noi chiamiamo
cloud computing
l'infinita quantità di conoscenze di
documenti di interazioni che abbiamo non
sono più in un luogo fisico non importa
dove siamo
poiché abbiamo se abbiamo un minimo di
connettività noi possiamo collegarci chi
vi parla voi guardate in rete definito
asta di nomad worker perché io non ho un
ufficio
io lavoro in mobilità datemi un po
dirette datemi un browser
datemi un mobile io lavoro questo
consente di lavorare di produrre di
consumare in un modo assolutamente
inedito ha smentito mia mamma mia mamma
un certo punto mi ha detto trovati un
posto di lavoro cioè la mia mamma
associava il lavoro ad un luogo fisico
perché si poteva lavorare solo
un fisico e poi successivamente era la
famosa scrivania quella con le tendine
le piantine le foto dei figli
quel luogo che in una qualche maniera
l'estensione del nostro ambiente
domestico ci trascinavamo l'ambiente
domestico in un altro luogo
ma oggi francamente per una parte
importante delle nostre professioni dove
siamo a scarsa importanza in una mia
precedente vita al dirigente del settore
urbanistica gli dicevo ma anima mia
le norme tecniche di attuazione dello
strumento urbanistico che tu le scriva
dalle 8 alle due presso la casa comunale
o che tu le scriva di notte a casa tua
mi interessa poco
a me serve as avere gli strumenti
necessari il frutto della tua produzione
noi abbiamo la città ancora organizzata
in modo fordista ma potremmo vivere in
una città decontestualizzata l'impatto
ambientale che oggi una dei grandi
problemi che abbiamo nelle nostre città
è dovuta al fatto che spesso tutti
insieme appassionatamente svolgiamo una
serie di funzioni tutti insieme alle 8
incorre in tangenziale a milano per fare
lavori che potremmo invece
tranquillamente farci un altro posto
perché perché noi continuiamo ancora a
ragionare ad operare come se fossimo in
un ambiente di contesti è finita la
città dei luoghi fisici comincia all
epoca della città decontestualizzata
siamo in una fase di transizione perché
c'è una funzione disponibile ma non
siamo ancora in grado di svolgerla fino
in fondo ma cominciate a pensare anche
dal punto di vista del consumo nei miei
primi 50 anni ho visto la fine dei
negozi di vicinato l'affermarsi di altre
forme di comprare di acquistare di
consumare ma oggi questo un modello che
ancor di più in transizione perché ormai
anche in questa sala anche se negherete
fino alla morte una parte dei nostri
acquisti natalizi li abbiamo fatti su
amazon e non l'abbiamo fatto agli orari
canonici e non l'abbiamo fatto come si
usava quando io ero piccino il sabato
andavamo e promette aveva dei grandi
vantaggi questa cosa che dal punto di
vita dell'umanità abbiamo comprato
quando c'è il più comodo se io dovessi
aspettare il mio ritorno a casa per
comprare i negozi di natale sarebbe un
triste natale li ho comprati su amazon
solo d'arrivo a casa li troverò già
stato un grande vantaggio
questo primo punto riguarda il tema
della città decontestualizzata gli
urbanisti a volte mi guardano così
quando gliela pongo perché il modo con
cui organizziamo gli ambienti urbani
oggi sono quelli fisici
dobbiamo cominciare a pensare di
organizzare la città che un grande
intellettuale si chiamava bobby c'è uno
dei fondatori del medialab delle mighty
definiva la città dei bit in un suo
straordinario saggio ti invito sempre
tutti a leggere questo il primo capitolo
del racconto che vi sto facendo perché
voi immediatamente messi ma l'uomo dove
sta l'uomo il centro nel mio racconto
vedete quella cosa che molti di noi
masticano si chiama smart city tema che
ormai comincia averli the rizzi ogni
volta della sento sussiste bolle rosse o
per piacere
fermatevi e stata troppo spesso
associata alla tecnologia più tecnologia
digitale tu hai più 6 smart è l'errore
più grave che uno possa fare nel
ragionare di questo queste aver visto
queste graduatorie di chi è più smart in
italia per cui milano inevitabilmente
prima e voi agrigento vela giocate
nell'essere ultimi e soprattutto o sei
grande
oppure non puoi essere smart l'idea per
cui le città smart phone o le metropoli
oppure quelli che hanno tanta tecnologia
non importa quante lì ma tu hai in una
classe
l'importante è come usi le lim i sistemi
educativi
a me interessano gli strumenti creati
sono solo strumenti per me l'uomo come
capite nella mia testa e il centro in
questo momento nel mondo in atto una
competizione feroce non fra stati la
città frare urbane competono le aree
urbane non più gli strati
su cosa competi nell'attirare risorse
umane
vedete che l'uomo torna sempre centro
uno che si chiama nomad worker pensa
sempre a dove si ferma un certo punto
non è che continua ragazzi da 5
settembre 53 ne ho viste di cose un
certo punto avrei un attimo mi fermo un
attimo dove il mister è legato a tanti
fattori ma sono tutti i fattori umani
il buon sistema educativo per mio figlio
per la mia famiglia un buon sistema
sanitario come sapere la mia età quindi
comincia un po pensare al futuro dove
vado in questa cosa un buon sistema dei
trasporti perché io continuerò a
muovermi
ricordate che ogni giorno sulla tratta
milano roma servita dall'alta velocità
si spostano decine di migliaia di
persone che lavorano in mobilità tutte
come meglio e sono la ricchezza più
ambita alla quale i governi urbani in
questo momento stanno pensando non
necessariamente io posso andare a milano
forse sono più attirato da una media
città di 50.000 abitanti ma deve avere
queste condizioni una delle pesanti
condizioni che io vi chiedo la capacità
di includere le città che discriminano
non vi interessa le città che non
esaltano la differenza non mi
interessano a me interessa la città che
esaltano le differenze restano mettere
insieme il sapere un insieme di cose
diverse
i pay mondi antichi non siamo più in
grado di difenderli vincono le aree
urbane che includono vincono le aree
urbane che sono in grado di valorizzare
le differenze vincolo le aree urbane che
sono in grado di trattenere gli studenti
universitari dopo gli studi
queste sono le aree urbane che vincono e
vinceranno non importa alla loro
dimensione
voi siete perfettamente in corsa ad
alcune condizioni naturalmente
altrimenti il no mad world si fermano
un'altra parte e la mia famiglia con me
si formerà da altre parti
ma per far questo terzo capitolo
bisognava risorse economiche che sono un
uomo molto realista ho fatto
l'amministratore di una grande città e
ragazzi ho gestito il bilancio
come finale sul sistema di welfare come
finanziò il sistema educativo perché le
risorse servono più semplicemente
facciamo le rotonde certo bisogna farle
facciamo mettiamo tutti voi avrete
sentito dire che i dati sono la
ricchezza del futuro
il petrolio del futuro e ciò è vero
quella fare che mi sono dimenticato in
giacca a quel mio iphone come tutto ciò
che attiene alle piattaforme digitali ha
una doppia funzione ricordatevelo sempre
a una funzione d'uso ed è quella che in
questo momento ci attira apple prima
assieme ad alcuni di voi guardavamo i
nostri reciproci aggeggi e guardavamo
quanto belle sono le foto le foto ua
l'effetto wow
la casa domotica e l'effetto wow ed è la
funzione d'uso ma sotto c'è una funzione
più ricca e la produzione di dati perché
ognuno di quegli aggeggi produce anche
dati nel momento in cui io mi collego a
facebook o una funzione d'uso di quella
piattaforma ma lascio a mark tanti bei
dati nel momento in cui utilizzo twitter
twitter ma lascio anche tanti dati nel
momento in cui instagram posto foto e
lascio un'infinita quantità di dati e
nel momento in cui il mondo degli
oggetti comincerà sempre di più ad
estendersi ci sarà una funzione d'uso di
quell'oggetto ma lascerò che una
quantità incredibile di dati e più
oggetti saranno in rete
non so se saranno 20 miliardi 30
miliardi
sembra 60 entro il 2020 chiusi saranno
una serie di funzioni civili legati
all'uso della sensoristica acqua
traffico luce gas risorse energetiche
semaforica fino alla domotica che nel
momento in cui ho interagiranno fra di
loro machine to machine o con noi
genereranno infinita quantità di dati
l'ambiente urbano sarà raccontato dai
sensori l'uomo è il palcoscenico o è
l'oggetto il palcoscenico perché su
questo dobbiamo metterci d'accordo per
me l'uomo è l'attore l'oggetto sta in
fondo ma l'importante è che gestisce
queste piattaforme
e chiaro che io le piattaforme di mark
zuckerberg non potrò mai gestire ma
quelle che forniscono acqua tutto il
mondo della sensoristica diffusa che
gestisce la sostenibilità ambientale
sono tutti dati di interesse pubblico
perché questo mercato e lo devo regalare
a google amazon e facebook
io ritengo che il futuro del
finanziamento nelle aree urbane sia la
capacità di riappropriarci del valore
dei dati che produciamo noi quella
miniera io non la lascio saccheggiare ad
altri il dato di interesse pubblico
l'utilizzo perché da quel dato io posso
ottenere un duplice valore
c'è un valore di predittività o una
quantità di dati incredibili sul futuro
della mia città che mi consente di
gestire meglio le risorse che io se io
sono in grado di avere i dati che mi
mettono in connessione le cartelle
cliniche delle persone livelli di co2 di
nx che sono in grado di fare
predittività sulla salute umana
e questa una funzione pubblica possono
usarla anche privati ma una funzione
pubblica e questo mi consente di essere
più rispettoso della vita umana e
contemporaneamente di generare valore
i sensori si ritiri dentro la tubatura
dell'acqua sono quelli in grado di dirmi
non solo la qualità dell'acqua ma anche
le eventuali dispersioni e quindi di
fare manutenzione predittiva la
manutenzione predittiva comporta un
grande valore per me non è il 2050 di
cui parlava e si può fare oggi è fatto
per essere chiari nel privato queste
risorse intellettuali per farlo ci sono
tutte perché il pubblico non può
servirsene
e poi c'è una seconda
io ritengo che qui sono un uomo molto
realista dobbiamo cominciare a pensare
ad una sorta di scambio privacy valore
io ritengo che anche il pubblico ad
alcune condizioni poste da vendere dati
il patto con il cittadino e il
finanziamento del welfare vedete il
grande dibattito in un paese su queste
cose andavano è solo il nostro tutta
l'europa il tema noi tassiamo i garanti
gli stiamo chiedendo le noccioline 500
milioni nel bilancio apple sono le
noccioline
il vero valore sui dati quindi certo
vanno tassati come siano tassati tutti
noi
ma la vera partita dei prossimi anni non
è la tassazione la vera partita la
capacità di utilizzare dati per generare
valore vedete parlavo ieri sera con
qualcuno a cena
e vero che il dato e petrolio ovviamente
abbondantemente raffinato questo è
chiaro ma come per il petrolio c'è una
borsa come per lo stagno per lo zinco
per loro per il platino c'è una borsa
noi dobbiamo cominciare a pensare alla
borsa dei dati cioè la capacità di
mettere in competizione fra di loro le
capacità di raffinare la capacità e
l'abilitazione a raffinare dati
certamente dei grandi piattaforme come
watson di pm e così via già sono delle
cose ma noi abbiamo bisogno di avere una
capacità pubblica di raffinare futuro
delle città si gioca su questo produrre
e gestire dati trovare le risorse per
finanziare l'inclusione ed avere la
grande capacità di pensare alla città
non più come la città dei luoghi quella
tutti in coda appassionatamente
ma la città dove siamo in grado di
modulare anche individualmente la nostra
vita è una città più ricche a quella
attualmente io una città più piena di
risorse e di opportunità è una città
dove tutti noi dobbiamo avere la forte
capacità di interagire con gli altri
io non solo voi avete capito a me
piacciono le tecnologie ci lavoro
eccetera
a me interessano poi rapporti umani io
studio le relazioni fra le persone le
tecnologie
e nel prossimo futuro l'interazione fra
persone persone oggetti oggetti uomini
oggetti qual è la semantica il
linguaggio perché finché parliamo fra di
noi linguaggio è chiara ma la semantica
che ci fa parlare con un oggetto qual è
quel linguaggio melo da google o lo
pensiamo noi lo traduciamo in linguaggio
umano
questa è la grande sfida dei prossimi
anni quindi io che vengo dal passato vi
dico occhio a ciò che può venire nel
futuro grazie
[Applauso]